THIS SITUATION?
>> NEVER PACK INTERCED
NECAS, KOKTKANIEMI TO
PUNCHES IT PAST
RAANTA.
2ND AND 3RD EFFORT
FROM JAKE LEFT
SIDE.
HE'S GONNA B
THE BOA.
DEANGELO, A DANGEROUS
OFFENSIVEE FORBORT
PICKING UP PEOPLESCE
THAT NEED TO BE
EFFORY
PASTRNAK, CARLO DISHE]
>>
AND A SCORE BY STAAL.
33 SECONDS INTO THE
2ND PERIOD.
TOTALLY DEANGELO,
THAT'S A DEFENCEMAN,
HE'S ALL OVER THE
OFFENSIVE ZONEELCYK.
BACK TO MARCHAND.
GETS A MAN BY MAN
CHANGE.
TOMAS
LOOKS LEFT, LOOK
RIGHT.
JAKE
AT IT LIKE THEY
WANTED SOME KIND OF 2S
THE REFEREE NUMBER
28.
REFEREE: AFTER THE
F
THEIT'S A GOOD LITTLE
PUMP FAKE  HAS GONE
MORE THAN 14 MINUTES
OF HOCKEY WITHOUT A
SHOT  ♪ ♪ ♪
>> JACK: LOW, FROM TSS
CAROLINA!
ANDSOLUTELY